are you guys even listening to me
okay it's time for some uh Mi the a-hole
quandries this is from Craig says Dear
Matt I have been watching you for years
but still can't call you Sweet Daddy
sorry well then you are I mean you're
already the a-hole we already know what
the answer is uh I recently came home
from the store with some blueberries my
daughter immediately asked for them and
wanted me to wash them for her something
my wife requires of all produce that
comes from the store I didn't want to so
I told my daughter that I didn't need to
because blueberries are naturally
antimicrobial of course my wife Came
Upon her munching the unwashed
blueberries and is now mad at me
reacting like I force fed my daughter
raw chicken or something to not lose
face in front of my daughter I simply
handed my wife a blueberry and asked her
to point to the offending microbe when
she couldn't immediately do it I claimed
Victory and retained the title of most
scientifically sound parent in my home
in my Viejo not for that I think that's
sound that's that's pretty good science
I think it's science of course the way
you started the email is one so you are
because of that but on this particular
issue anyway uh that's just science and
look I know they said you know people
yeah some people are pretty diligent and
obsessive about hey you gotta wash all
the produce I I don't you know it's not
going to kill you it's not going to kill
you or maybe it will I don't know how do
you know
but that's always been that's my health
guidance is that you know if you do
something you eat something it doesn't
kill you on the spot that's probably
fine this is why I'm not a nutritionist
Susie says hi Matt my husband and I have
three very young daughters and he also
has a teenage boy and girl with an
ex-wife he and his ex-wife have a
contentious relationship and their kids
live with her and their stepfather in a
different state I've only met his kids a
handful of times and didn't have any
relationship with them his ex-wife does
not help to Foster any relationship
between him and the kids but now that
the teenage boy is displaying behavioral
issues she wants him to come live with
his father naturally my husband wants to
have him move in with us I told my
husband that this is not an option as we
have three young children we're raising
and I don't think it's fair to disrupt
their lives in that way I'm also
extremely uncomfortable with a troubled
teenage boy who uh who my children do
not know suddenly living in a home with
them I barely know the boy and my
husband works all the time so I would
also be responsible for caring for him a
majority of the time my husband says
that he understands that it's a lot to
ask of me but he thought I'd be more
supportive I would never do anything to
jeopardize my daughter say your
stability so I will not permit his son
to live with us the boys being raised by
two parents who are well off and he also
has his sister with him I believe
they're the ones who need to deal with
his behavioral issues but I also feel a
measure of guilt because of the pain the
situation causes my husband am I the
a-hole uh I can tell you the a-hole but
I think you are wrong I think you are
wrong and this is some of this is the
unwinnable lose-lose
situation that is created by divorce I
get emails like this all the time for
this segment and other segments and uh
it's like it's always you know it's like
a long story about the husband's divorce
my wife's divorced here's what's going
on in the family Nick's family and a lot
of problems what's the way through this
what's the solution well there is no
perfect solution it's just when when
families are broken apart it creates a
lot of lose-lose situations it creates a
lot of situations where there is no
great answer
and this is one of them but I will say
that that is his son
his responsibility to his son
and uh I don't think you can tell
a man I don't think you can tell your
husband that he can't have his son live
with him now I I know this is again this
goes to the unwinnable situation where
you guys are married he has a child and
you don't care at all about the child
um it seems fair to characterize it that
way that's why it's so much easier when
families stay together because then you
you share the children and hopefully you
have a mutual love and concern for the
children but here you know you don't
have that but yet that is his son that's
his child that's his boy so no I don't I
don't I don't think you can tell I don't
think it's right to tell your husband
that he can't have his own son be in his
house with him what's the biggest summer
secret to a great looking glowing summer
complexion it's having great skincare
products from our friends at genu sale
you know dehydrated skin covered in dark
spots and even puffier bags under the
eyes are a problem for all of us gen
your cells beautifully curated summer
Essentials package is a limited edition
package that includes their
one-of-a-kind Ultra retinol super
moisturizer their Ultra retinol is a
powerful plant extract alternative to
retinol without the harsh side effects
and it's perfectly safe for use in the
Summer sun plus you'll get Jenny cell's
classic skin care therapy for under eye
bags and puffiness and concentrated
vitamin C serum to nourish your skin for
a visibly clear complexion with a glow
that will get compliments everywhere you
go our assistant director Austin has
freakishly large under eye bags and they
seem to be growing every day it looks
like his skin is slowly shriveling up
and it's all just becoming one giant
under eye bag it's grotesque to look at
needless to say it's extremely upsetting
for me really puts me in a bad head
space before I start my show so I've
forced Austin to start using genucel and
just like magic his eyes no longer look
like they packed bags for a month-long
vacation overseas so go to
genyourself.com Walsh YT right now to
get your genucel summer Essentials
package just for the summer every
subscription order includes a customized
summer spa gift box absolutely free it's
genucel.com walshyt genucel.com Walsh
white what's next
from cool dad dear sweet daddy my two
kids my wife and I were headed up North
for a day of skiing after two hours in
the car my wife had to stop and use the
restroom at a gas station
we stopped at a gas station in the
middle of nowhere they had eight pumps
with one person gassing up and zero cars
to be seen for at least a mile the
ground was covered in 10 inches of fresh
snow so I pulled up to the 12-foot
section of cleared pavement uh to allow
my wife to get inside without walking in
10 inches of snow I then parked in the
nearest spot that was handicapped so
that when she came out she wouldn't have
to walk in the snow for the record there
were two handicapped spots on either
side of the 12-foot cleared pavement the
gas station attendant about my same age
then comes out and starts screaming at
me demanding that I prove that I'm
handicapped I responded with what
difference does it make who am I
blocking from parking in the spot he
screams and shouts it doesn't matter
you're not handicapped I continue to sit
there stare them down and refuse to move
as we drive away he literally jumps and
shouts you entitled people don't come
back did he shake his fist as well tell
me he shook his fist don't you dare come
back why yeah as we got back on the
freeway we all laughed at it and I used
it as a teaching opportunity to tell my
kids not to be scared of people like
that and use common sense it has now
become a memorable funny family story
uh no no not at all not at all I mean
first of all I would have responded to
the guy okay first of all it handicap is
not the you know it's disabled or not
even disabled what is it what's the
what's the term of art now I don't even
think it's disabled it's definitely not
handicapped can't say that anymore I'm
not handicapped there I'm sorry
differently uh advantaged so I would
responded by saying I'm offended that
you're using that you're using the H
word okay don't speak to me that way but
this is yeah some people are are yes
look taking up a handicap spot
uh and going into to Walmart because you
don't feel like walking farther and then
someone who is actually disabled can't
access it that makes you a giant jerk
for sure
but this idea that like no one else is
around and you can't even just park
there real quick so that you're so as
you say your wife can go in without
having to strip on the snow and in the
ice
um that that's that's absurd it's like
there's as you said you're not stopping
anyone from using the the spot there's
nobody around this is not an issue
you're not preventing it you're not
doing anything you're not causing any
harm to anybody
um but it's what on some weird principle
that even though there's nobody else
around you can't be in the magic spots I
also think in general when you've got a
snowstorm situation and there's snow all
over the place
then the rules of the parking lot change
and at that point it's kind of like I've
always thought it's sort of every man
for himself at that point like there's
not you know you can't even see where
the spots are there are not a lot of
places you can go
um and you got to kind of just pull up
where you can because there's nowhere
else to be it seems like that's the
situation you were in this situation
where you have to choose between
being a good husband and taking care of
your wife so that she doesn't slip and
trip on the snow when she has to use the
bathroom uh so you can you know be be a
good respectful husband or you can
respect the handicap spot even though
there's nobody around so you had to
choose between those two things and I
think in that case you choose correctly
finally from Anonymous I am a
stay-at-home mom to a four-month-old
baby my life is perfect except one
problem I hate my husband's dog it is a
seven-year-old dog he got before we met
I do 100 of the housework which I'm not
complaining about I love taking care of
the house and my husband my problem is I
have to take care of the dog too he
barks and wakes my baby he's constantly
shedding I hate the dog hair on my socks
so I have to vacuum daily I have more
reasons but I know you just want me to
get to the point my husband owns a
company so he's way too busy to take
care of the dog am I the a-hole if I
re-home the dog simply because I hate it
uh no you are absolutely not at all you
are singing my my tune here I'm in a
very similar situation in fact except
roles are reversed with the dog in that
case and uh no look people are gonna
like me saying this get rid of the dog
give the dog to you know if you find
someone who wants the dog and it'll be
fine if you're under no obligation to be
miserable for the sake of a dog and and
you take priority over the freaking dog
your baby takes priority over the dog so
yes that's how I feel you know they
could they can
there's going to be the the Pitchfork
mob outside of my my door for this but
um a perfectly valid reason to get rid
of a pet is that it's making your life
difficult and it's it's not fun to have
the pet like having a pet is supposed to
be fun it gets to a point where it's
just not fun anymore and it's nothing
but a burden and it's annoying all the
time
um you can be miserable for no apparent
reason or you can't give the animal to
somebody who wants the animal your
mother and I have been thinking about
giving the puppies away
no you know what you know something the
dog will be fine the dog will really be
fine the dog will bond with a new owner
and he'll forget all about the old
owners he just will because he's a dog I
know you think that uh the dog is bonded
to me for life and no not really the dog
can go somewhere else and forget that
you've ever ever existed
because he's a dog and that's the way it
goes all right many will disagree many
will say that you are Diego and that I
am for everything that we've talked
about just now but you and I we know the
truth uh and we'll leave it there for
today
that's how I roll
[Music]
how much